[Musique]
chers amis bien le bonjour chez vous
aujourd'hui nous sommes à cheboksary une
ville russe située à 650 km à l'est de
moscou
son histoire remonte au 15e siècle c'est
la capitale de la slovaquie république
majoritairement peuplé de chiu vaches le
cinquième peuple de la russie
[Musique]
à cheboksary il y a beaucoup d'églises
et de monastères en activité aujourd'hui
nous allons nous rendre dans l'un des
plus anciens d'entre eux le monastère de
la sainte trinité
[Musique]
en ce moment les chrétiens orthodoxes
fait le baptême du christ les moines se
prépare aux offices qui vont être
dirigés par notre hôte d'aujourd'hui
pierre pasquier connu aussi sous le nom
de père bazine allons faire sa
connaissance
[Musique]
bonjour père vasile bonjour yade ça me
fait plaisir les mêmes goûts
c'est magnifique très content de vous de
vous connaître vous avez choisi le jour
avec -30 meilleure température mais
c'est ça la russie c'est ça que d'un
c'est magnifique
elle venait vous pouvez montrer le
monastère le monastère a pris naissance
au 16e siècle
ivan le terrible avait décidé d'en faire
une forteresse qu il décide aussi de
faire don d'en faire une ville c'est la
naissance de la ville de tubes axa et la
naissance de notre monastère
on voit trois personnages trois saints
qui arrive de moscou en bateau par la
volga
oui et ils ont ordre par ivan le
terrible de bénir la future ville et de
célébrer une liturgie à l'endroit de la
future cathédrale est aujourd'hui la
cathédrale principal la plus ancienne
qui 'n'amène jusqu'au xxème siècle viiie
siècle alors là c'est l'arrêt total de
la vie du monastère donc les moines sont
expulsés ils sont tués
le monastère est en partie détruit ce
sont des choses qui reste de l'ancien
monastère ou à ce bâtiment là cette
église
ce qu'on voit derrière nous le mur cc
déjà l'époque moderne c'est nous qui
l'avons construite n'a qu'à le clocher a
été rasée à 0 l'église la sainte trinité
avait été transformée en théâtre de
marionnettes
ici c'était librairie club club pour les
parachutistes partir de quand tout est
reparti et bien c'est à l'époque de
eltsine
c'est à dire depuis 1993 menacèrent
fonctionne on dira plein donc on à
reconstruire l'église si les principales
l'église de la sainte-trinité aulas on a
reconstruit le clocher en a qui est ici
on a une école spirituel c'est à dire ça
pour la formation des futurs prêtres
on a une école du dimanche et puis on a
une petite ferme enfin deux fermes de
petites fermes mais elles sont elles
sont à l'extérieur soit 30 et 70 km
d'ici on a une trentaine de moines vingt
deux moines de postulants de gens qui
viennent regarder la cellule ici
habitent ici voilà chacun sa petite
cellule et habiter ici
oui donc voilà ça c'est c'est la maison
de ligue ou même malades
c'est aussi la maison un petit peu
administrative mais j'habite aussi dans
les sous le toit voilà je suis très
curieuse j'aimerais bien que vous vous
montriez et si on revient en valais
[Musique]
votre cellule est votre petit endroit
parasites
c'est ici vous êtes vous fait votre
prière donc c'est bien ça la rivière
personnel avec tous ses saints autour
d'eux et ça et puis vous voyez le
psautier le psautier livre de prières
sont en français oui le psautier
liturgiques orthodoxes
ça vous arrive aussi de faire des
prières en français
quand je suis seul je prie en français
donc ce sont tous nos ça il ya même
sainte geneviève sainte geneviève de
paris par exemple quand il ya eu les
attentats quand il ya eu tout ça je
mettais des cierges sainte-geneviève
pour protéger les français
voilà
voyons à raconter un petit peu aussi
quelles sont vos fonctions en tant que
vicaire dans ce monastère
oui bon le vicaire c'est c'est l'abbé du
monastère
c'est à dire que bon c'est l'évêque qui
est qui a le titre principal de père
abbé mais comme il peut pas gérer le
monastère donc juridiquement c'est moi
qui ai la charge du monastère la
responsabilité juridique gérance
économique
la gérance moral c'est-à-dire
l'éducation des frères le suivi des
frères spirituel donc le père abbé est
aussi est aussi et doit être le père
spirituel de tous les moines de du
monastère et vous parliez de votre salle
de prière est ce que il ya que celle-ci
vous en avez une autre encore dans le
sud cc c'est personnel personnel
c'est-à-dire n'y a personne vous êtes le
premier qui monte ici
le monteur qui qui monte ici c'est le
lieu intime si la chambre haute
elle sera en plus c'est symbolique on
est sous les toits donc c'est vraiment
la chambre haute allant chez j'ai une
petite chapelle en bas c'était à
l'origine c'était ma cellule mais comme
cellule ça ne me plaisait pas il y avait
trop de trop de fenêtres et j'ai trouvé
des artistes qui n'ont pas la chapelle
ont pas les murs c'est devenu très joli
très jolie en plus j'ai trouvé des
artistes qui ont fait l'iconostase
s'étouffer avec des artistes du lieu et
c'est faire la main
vous êtes né d'une famille catholique
quand il tout à fait arrive-t-on à
l'orthodoxie
moi j'y suis arrivé en avion en arrive à
un masque ou non c'est une blague quand
j'ai eu 17 ans 18 ans j'ai fait
connaissance avec une communauté de rite
oriental grecs catholiques qui devenu ma
communauté
ça m'a tout de suite saisi et ça m'a
tout de suite plu et le contact avec
l'eau taux de 6 pour moi ça a été le
coup de foudre une maladie et d'amour
[Musique]
pierre pasquier est né en 1958 en vendée
à côté du village de tiffauges il n'est
au sein d'une famille nombreuse
catholique pratiquante
pierre est le septième de neuf enfants
sa mère décède alors qu'il n'a que 9 ans
à 10 ans pierre commence à aider le
prêtre au mess du matin en semaine ainsi
que le dimanche
le soir il travaille à la ferme à 20 ans
pierre quitte la maison familiale et par
dhr sud de la france pour faire ses
études au lycée technique agricole de
castelnaudary pierre rejoint alors la
communauté grecque catholique de la
théophanie à limoux où il travaille en
tant qu'assistant du responsable de la
ferme
c'est là que naît son désir d'entrer en
religion
pierre prend l'habit et en 1981 à l'âge
de 22 ans devient le frère basile
la même année il est envoyé dans un
monastère grec catholique à jérusalem où
il passera en tout dix ans le patriarche
orthodoxe de jérusalem benoît premier et
l'orthodoxie en général les influencent
beaucoup
et après sa rencontre avec deux prêtres
russe il prend la décision de se
convertir à l'orthodoxie
[Musique]
début 1994 il part en russie où il
visite d'abord un haut lieu de
l'orthodoxie dans les îles dahlab
quelques mois plus tard il entre
officiellement dans l'église orthodoxe
russe
il est d'abord envoyé dans un monastère
apps cov comme simple moine puis
transféré en torchis dans un petit
village où il devient prêtre et déménage
ensuite à à la tire une ville sauvage où
il sert en tant que prêtre pendant plus
de dix ans par décret présidentiel en
1998 le père base il obtient la
nationalité russe et en 2009
le père base il est nommé à cheboksary
au monastère de la sainte trinité où il
réside et officie jusqu'à aujourd'hui
en 2011 il est nommé archimandrite l'un
des plus haut titre de l'église
orthodoxe russe
oui vous êtes donc partie d'un certain
certain nombre d'années ça s'est fait
facilement
ce départ de france vous le vouliez par
rapport à votre famille niaré il y avait
le goût de l'aventuré bien sûr ouais
mais je savais que j'allais dans un pays
en révolution parce que c'était après
octobre 93
ouais il y avait la maison blanche rue
saint cloud qui vous l avez les émeutes
dans les rues et tout le monde me disait
mais t'es pas un peu cinglé d'aller en
russie à ce moment là c'est un lien j'ai
commencé j'avais pensé mais je dis non
le seigneur m'a peine là bas se dire que
je dois avoir quelque chose à faire là
bas
est-ce que vous arrive de rentrer en
france en france
dans un an maintenant ça fait la
dernière fois que la france était en
2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non non non parfois vous savez c'est
difficile parce que la france n'est plus
que ce que n'était quand je les ai
quittés il ya un certain décalage et
j'arrive je me retrouvais vous avez
appris le russe facilement non j'ai pas
le temps je n'ai pas encore appris on
vous parlait très bien j'ai commencé à
apprendre le russe par moscou parce que
moscou c'est un petit peu comment dire
l'exotisme le français qui est arrivé
donc tous les russes qui parlaient
français voulait parler en france avec
un possible d'apprendre le russe avec
des cours intensifs
non même pas c'était plutôt des épreuves
intense il parce que
bien sûr on m'envoyait faire dès qu'on
dit les obédiences et je comprenais rien
en effet ceux-ci moi je faisais cela
parce que je comprenais pas ce qu'on
voulait de moi
on n'avait même pas insulter mon père
m'avait dit comme ça l'économe du
monastère on m'avait dit bahram c'est un
mouton à rien c'était pas que je
comprenais rien mais je n'arrive pas à
saisir ce qu'ils voulaient ils me disent
allez à droite jallet à gauche par
exemple mais il ya des choses qui se
transmet n'y a pas besoin de langage il
ya des choses comme ça par exemple quand
je suis arrivé au monastère de daube
score pendant deux heures j'ai rencontré
le père jean christian kill avec ils me
parlaient en russe
moi je ne connaissais pas le russe et je
comprenais tout ce qui me disait est ce
que vous avez dit temps libre c'est ça
c'est difficile à dire parce qu'on est
toujours occupée il ya toujours des
activités il ya toujours bon
demandent-ils lemoine quelqu'un qui doit
prier sans cesse même pas simplement le
moins de chrétiens
donc on on est toujours occupée quelque
chose mais bien sûr c'est comment dire
tout est relatif
des moments libres vraiment libre non
[Musique]
une fois par semaine le père base il
donne des cours de catéchisme à l'école
du dimanche
nous avons 600 me laver joue aujourd'hui
en ce début d'année les étudiants de
l'école donne un concert
[Musique]
oh
cette école du dimanche n'est pas que
pour les enfants elle est aussi pour les
adultes tout le monde y trouver une
nourriture spirituelle
le père vasile a sûrement un don pour
sentir finement intuitivement et
spirituellement la personne avec
laquelle ils communiquent
à ces scènes
[Musique]
il n'a pas besoin de livres il sent son
auditoire
il écoute les questions et il a toujours
la réponse qu'il nous donnera pour que
les gens comprennent comme jésus-christ
parler avec des paraboles
il raconte des histoires des exemples
[Musique]
mongenan il faut penser en russe pour
pouvoir exprimer des choses si sage de
manière compréhensible qu'ils m'ont dit
le ministre il est tout à fait russe il
nous comprend et nous le comprenons
aussi l'orthodoxie pour vous qu'est ce
que c'est quelle est sa mission pour moi
l'orthodoxie c'est devenu ma vie c'est
c'est ma foi c'est c'est ma façon d'être
des secours stoxx aujourd'hui c'est donc
le baptême du christ c'est un jour un
grand jour c'est un jour de lumière les
grecs l'appellent la fête des lumières
donc c'est l'apparition l'apparition du
christ sa manifestation
donc c'est il entre dans le bade dans le
jourdain jean baptiste lebas tease et le
montrent il dit voici l'agneau de dieu
et il dit jean baptiste moi je vous ai
baptisé avec de l'eau c'est un baptême
de pénitence mais lui il va vous baptisé
dans le feu du saint-esprit
[Musique]
oh
lors de cette journée le père vasile
célèbre plusieurs liturgie
nous avons reçu du plié l'animation
[Musique]
sept fils liturgique s'achève par une
procession il va bénir la source
non pas vraiment
après avoir béni la source tout le monde
peut prendre l'eau bénite et le père
bazil va bénir sa maison avec ses tons
dans le jourdain lorsqu'un seniors s'est
fait baptiser
à l'univers fut révélé la sainte trinité
en ta faveur et entendre la voix du père
de désignant comme son fils bien aimé
est à toi jan bonne fête du baptême
voilà à les félicitations sommes au bord
de la volga le plus long fleuve d'europe
une des traditions lors de la fête du
baptême du christ et de plongée dans un
trou découpé dans la glace lors des
gelées de la théophanie des plus grands
froids de l'année et il va falloir
respecter la tradition
[Musique]
il fait au moins 24 dehors il fait plus
quatre à l'intérieur vous pouvez me
souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
ouah
quelle est la différence principale
entre les années 90 et maintenant selon
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont changé
entre autres quand je suis arrivé les
magazines étaient super vide les
étalages était il y avait rien
qu'est ce qui me choque encore en russie
après toutes ces années
parfois le manque d'organisation parfois
par exemple on commence les travaux
quand il commence à pleuvoir les travaux
de aurait parlé route quand il ya la
neige ont fait qu'est ce que vous
préférez l'île de ré où les gelées de la
théophanie les jeux et les fans et ouais
c'est quelque chose qui est plus
important oui j'ai commencé mon mes
premiers pas en russie par le plongeon
d'abord j'ai eu peur et puis ensuite
j'ai fait ma révolution dans ma tête et
j'ai pensé qu' il faut que je me plonge
sinon mon intégration réussie sera ratée
qu'est ce qui me plaît le plus en russie
l'amitié les gens qu'il est votre
activité préféré servir servir ces je
suis prêtre et être avec le peuple trick
les gens votre mission pervasif un grand
merci pour votre temps et pour votre
hospitalité
merci bientôt revoir
[Musique]
notre séjour à cheboksary touche à sa
fin nous avons rencontré un homme
extraordinaire le père vasile de
nouvelles aventures très intéressante
vous attendre je vous dis donc
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]